اصداء الحكم الصادر من محكمه النقض ببراءه
سيده بعد الحكم عليها بالاعدام شنقا ما
زالت تتوالى السيده كريمه التي اتهمت بقتل
زوجها عمدا مع سبق الاسراء والترصد قضت ست
سنوات من السجن بينها اربع سنوات مرتديا
بدل الحمراء انتظارا لتنفيذ حكم وما حصل
معها امر لا يتكرر كثيرا حيث تكون معظم
الاحكام الصادره من محكمه النقد بالنزول
عن العقوبه من الاعدام للمؤبده والسجن
المشدد وهو ما يعرف بتخفيف العقوبه لكن ان
تنزل البراءه مباشره فهو امر نادر التكرار
تعالي يا كريمه انت خدتي براءه بهذه
الكلمات تم ابلاغ السيده كريمه بالحكم فلم
تصدق او تستوعب انها ستعود مره اخرى
لبناتها وقريتها رافعه راسها بعد تبرئتها
النهارده مولوده جديد واسعد واحده في
حياتي عشان ولادي جنبي وفي حضني والناس دي
كلها جايه حبان في ربنا وفيا ربنا طلعني
براءه ثم القضاء العالي اللي ذاكر قضيتي
والقلي مش مدانا فيها جامي جميل الابراج
كلها
[موسيقى]
في قلب ان انا اتحطيت في
وجعه
من القاهره ينضم الينا كل من السجين
السابقه وصاحبه حكم البراءه من الاعدام
كريم السيد ومعها محاميها وهدان فاروق
اهلا بك السيده الكريمه واهلا بالاستاذ
وهدان اولا بدنا نسمع منك كريمه الف مبروك
على البراءه وكيف كان شعورك بالبراءه بعد
حكم الاعدام
الحمد لله
اسعد بني ادمه في حياتي اللي انا خرجت
بالسلامه لاولادي واخواتي
وبحمد ربنا وبشكر فضله وبفضل من ربنا ثم
القضاء العالي اللي ذاكر قضيتي اللي اداني
براءت فيها
ثم بشكر الاستاذ فاروق ودان الباز المحامي
بتاعي اللي ذاكر قضيتي وقدر يتواصل
البراءه بتاعتي انا بشكره انا في المكتبه
دلوقتي
وانا بشكر الاستاذ فاروق وهدان الباز ده
بعد ربنا سبحانه وتعالى يا كريم يتواصل
لبراءتي بفضل من ربنا يعني الحياه يا
كريمه حبت تكون كريمه معاك تديكي كمان
عمري عمري جديد حياتي مدمره
حماتي متدمره حياتي مدمره جدا انا طالعه
ما كنتش
الحمد لله والشكر لله بفضل من ربنا برضو
انا دخلت السجن ما كنتش مريضه انا كنت
مريضه بالغضروف بس ورجليها مكسوره انا
طالعه من السجن في يا جماعه امراض ربنا
وانا انا بحمد ربنا وبشكر فضله على قضائه
الاعتراض ولا لون في حكم ربنا انا بطالب
باي دكتور يتولى حالتي
ويتابع معايا
وبتكلم الساده المشاهدين اللي متابعيني
وسامعيني انا بطالب ان انا اقف على رجلي
عشان اشق طريق واشوف مصالحي واكل عيالي
بالحلال طيب السيد وهدان اقف على رجلي
ونفسي صحتي ترجع لي زي الاول تاني يا رب
يا كريمه انه يكفي انه بناتك هلا
طيب سيد وهدان فيها جلطه طيب
في لاول مره يلغى حكم الاعدام منذ عام 86
في مصر كيف كان شعورك وكيف قدرت تنتزع حكم
الاعدام وتجيب البراءه كريمه تفضل
بصي هو الموضوع بدا من يوم 5/12/2017 يوم
وفاه المغفور له محمد زوج كريمه
بالقتل بشرب القهوه مدسوس بها السن طبعا
صدر حكم اتنين تسعه 2019 من محكمه جنايات
المنصوره باجماع الاراء بالاعدام شنقا
للسيده كريمه الحمد لله اودعنا اودعنا
مذكره بالنقد
بعد ما ودعنا مذكره النهضه تحدد لها جلسه
بعد اربع سنين يعني هي فضلت سنتين تحقيقات
لابسه البدله البيضاء بعد كده قعدت اربع
سنين لابسه البدله الحمراء من سنه من يوم
2/9/2019 حتى تاريخ
17/1/2023 اللي الحمد لله قدر لنا فيها
بالبراءه يمكن الحمد لله لما كنا فيها
بالبراءه كانت مساله فنيه بحته وهي مساله
توقيت شرب القهوه بالنسبه لزوجها المغفور
له محمد طبعا كان في ذات اليوم ده اللي هو
هو كان في خلافات زوجيه سابقه وكان كريمه
ما شافتش محمد قبلها باسبوع لانه كان قاعد
عند اهله في بلد تانيه في منيه النصر لما
جه في اليوم ده الساعه سته قاعد على
الكافتيريا الساعه 6:30 قعد حوالي ساعتين
من سته ونصف ل 8:30 على الكافتيريا
كافتيريا الانثى من محل الدمنه انتقل على
اسرها وقال لي لصاحبه اللي كان قاعد معاه
محمد منجل انا هقوم الوقت وهروح عند زوجتي
علشان ادي لها فلوس علشان بنتها تعمل
عمليه يعني الامور كانت طبيعيه وما فيش اي
حاجه لما انتقل الساعه تسعه وراح الساعه
تسعه ونص على كلام شهود الاثبات وتحريرات
المباحث ان طلع الساعه 9:30 الكريمه
الوفاء حدثت الساعه 11:15 جيت تليفون
لصاحبه محمد منجل وهو قاعد على الكافتيريا
قال له ايه قال له الحقني يا محمد انا
بطني بتتقطع كان الكلام ده الساعه 11:15
وتمت على اسرار الوفاه الساعه 11:30 من
الطب الشرعي في زياده التوقيت ان تمت
الوفاه احنا تمكننا ان احنا نشوف توقيت
الماده الفعاله الماده الفعاله بالنسبه
لاملاح الفوسفيد اللي هي اربع ساعات لازم
عشان تتفاعل مع جسم الانسان ويحدث الوفاه
بتحدث من اربع ساعات وقد تصل لاربعه ايام
احنا قدمنا الكلام ده فبالتالي لما هو شرب
القهوه ما كانش قاعد عند السيده كريمه ده
كان قاعد على الكافتيريا كافتيريا الانس
بمحل الدمنه وبناء عليه محكمه النقد
شرفتنا وانصفتنا وادتنا حكم بالغاء حكم
اول درجه والقضاء مجددا ببراءه المتهمه
البريئه انا لسه نسالها يعني كتير في
اسئله بس للاسف انتهى الوقت يعني محامي
صاحبه حكم البراءه من الاعدام كريم السيد
وايضا المحامي وهدان فاروق شكرا جزيلا
لكما على حضوركما معا